Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys are the like button, if you enjoy the video.
And yeah, let's begin.
What's going on.
Guys? This is Robin.
We are picking back up again with the conclusion of Spider-Man. Yes, we are.
We are wrapping up the Spiderman event, uh,
and this is probably the single most important part of the story.
Not necessarily because of what's happened so far,
but because of the future of miles Morales.
So what we end up doing here is we initially pick up with Mysterio.
Mysterio is suffering from the same problem that every supervillain suffers from
stupidity. So the idea behind this with Mysteria.
So the idea behind this with Mysterio is that he comes to the realization that
he actually unintentionally defeated Spiderman that with Spiderman being whisked
off into this other dimension, where Peter Parker in that reality is dead,
that it leaves no Spiderman.
And this universe right in the main Marvel universe,
there is no Peter Parker here, right?
He's often the ultimate universe somewhere.
And it was something that Mysterio had not really thought of before.
And now he realizes it like, man, dude, okay.
Like I actually defeated Spiderman, but then the question becomes,
why isn't it enough? Right? Like, why is it not enough? He's like,
I have to see it. Right. I have to see him suffer and die.
I'll just take a peak for myself. Just for one moment. Now this is Brian,
Michael Bendis being Brian, Michael Bendis. If it were me writing this story,
it would be like, Oh man, dude, on one, cool. The end. And that would be it.
Right.
It would be Mysterio realizing he basically got the upper hand on Peter Parker
and there's no,
no more Spider-Man here such as it is then is one of the Telus stories. And so,
so basically mysterial comes to the realization that he wants to actually see
Spiderman, suffer and die. And so he reopened,
he basically reactivates the portal and takes a peek inside only for webbing to
come flying out and eviction basically attach itself to him.
And then of course you have Peter Parker,
you have miles Morales and the Ultimate's team who's there like the ultimate
Avengers who were all there. And it's kind of like, well, crap, right? Like,
well, like that's basically yet, right? Like, okay. I mean,
who could have possibly seen that coming? The cool thing about this though,
is that one thing to understand what the stereo is.
He's usually always got an ACE up his sleeve and that's one of the things that
makes him so dangerous. Right? And so where you have Nick fury,
you've got the rest of the guys who were kind of like cool. The day saved.
Keep in mind,
they're not used to the kind of villains you have in the main Marvel universe
were somehow they always have some kind of an escape plan or something like
that.
You remember the main mobile universe is a lot less realistic than the ultimate
universe was.
And so Mysterio immediately types away and just starts releasing a whole host of
these chemicals and sets off an explosion. And when that happens,
basically everybody here. So like I eman Nick fury miles, Morales,
all these various guys are met by what are essentially their worst nightmares.
Why there's literally what they're exposed to using the power of Mysterio.
He exposes all of them to their worst nightmares, right?
So you've got all the Ultimate's who were dead at the hands of Tony stark,
which of course is definitely an illusion to what we saw in the Marvel cinematic
universe. You've got Nick fury, who's watching the world on fire,
watching the world burn green goblin has killed aunt Mae and the in,
in front of a, I'm sorry, really Dr.
Octopus and green goblin have killed on may in front of Spider-Man.
And then you've got the Prowler who killed miles, Miralis mother and father.
And so because of that,
where everybody else is kind of succumbing this Myles sort of succumbs to it a
little bit, but then manages to get the upper hand on it,
even if only for a moment. And when that happens,
he realizes Mysterio is making a break for the portal and he tackles mysterious.
Now by all standards of measurement, miles should have,
should have been 100% incapacitated here. And again,
that's kind of the critique of Bendis right. Ben, this is just, well, of course,
miles while it has to be on top. He's the guy that I'm writing right now.
He's the main Spider-Man we can't have him lose. Right. So it's kinda like,
okay, you know, it's sort of, Hey, he's going to go with it in this story,
right. It's just kind of the way that Bendis does it,
but where you end up having the stereo,
who of course uses his powers on miles yet again,
he almost gets the upper hand miles Dodge,
the attack goes invisible and the mysterial trying to figure out what happens,
ends up being attacked by miles. Again. Now, again, this is kind of,
Bendis basically saying like, this is how capable Myles is.
Now the reality of this is that while this was kind of, I wouldn't say far Fest,
but kind of like what in the world's going on here, you know, back in the day,
in this day and age, it's common practice. And it kind of makes sense.
I think that with this story and,
and miles being able to overcome mysterious so fast,
despite mysterious abilities was really more of just,
Bendis wanting to tell the story as opposed to just kind of letting it play out
organically. In reality,
having somebody like Mysterio was probably not the best bet.
It probably should have been somebody more like Dr.
Octopus because mysterious powers are not limited to just some kind of tentacles
attached to his back, that that go after you, but he messes with your mind,
he messes with your head.
And so there isn't really a whole lot of reason to believe that miles would
somehow be able to overcome this so quickly. Right?
If you're trying to maintain that kind of comic book lore that we're used to,
and kind of maintain consistency thin, you know,
it's something you would kind of expect,
but with Peter Parker able to overcome it as well, alongside miles,
they take up material pretty quickly, right? He's defeated pretty fast.
And so from that point,
what they ended up doing is actually keeping Mysterio inside the ultimate
universe.
And the reason why is because mysterial now knows that Peter Parker Spider-Man
and so it kind of creates this situation where Peter's like, okay, cool. Yeah,
man, hold on to them. I appreciate it guys. Thanks for looking out.
It's kind of a shady thing to do,
but this is really the most important moment that comes out of this, right?
Which is why we kind of more or less ham-fisted our way through this.
There's a point where Peter and miles are talking and Peter basically,
thanks him for keeping the legacy of Spiderman going. And when miles asked him,
like, does that mean that I have your blessing? Peter's like, absolutely.
This was Brian, Michael, Bendis giving a big middle finger to the naysayers.
And we talked about that before that when miles first showed up,
there were a lot of people who were really pissy about the fact that Peter
Parker in the alternate universe had been killed and they wanted,
they didn't want miles. They wanted Peter Parker. The response has been,
this is you already have Peter Parker. You've had him for like 50 years, right?
You've had Peter Parker for a long, long time. You need to get over yourselves,
right? It's time for a new Spiderman.
It's time to kind of continue on this story, focusing on somebody else.
We can't do that in the main Marvel universe because Peter Parker is etched in
stone, forevermore, the Spiderman in the main Marvel universe.
We can't change that. Marvel editorial, well, let me change it.
And even if I wanted to, it'd be a terrible idea to do it anyway.
But in the ultimate universe, I created this character. Bendis giveth.
Bendis take it away, take it away. And that's kind of,
that's kind of a stance on that.
And so when you had a lot of people who were giving him flack and really
complaining a lot on the various forum boards and social media,
different things like that,
about miles Morales taking over the role of Spiderman in the ultimate universe.
This was really been to saying, no, he's not going anywhere, right.
If what you expected me to do was to basically give in acquiesce and admit,
defeat and say, Hey, you know, you,
you 50 comic book fans who sound like 5 million.
Obviously you guys don't like miles miles.
So let me just get rid of him and bring back Peter Parker.
If that's what you were expecting, then I'm sorry, you're gravely mistaken.
That's not what's going to happen.
And so we ended up just getting miles more Alice going forward.
And so as one of these things, where with,
with miles kind of getting the official blessing of Peter Parker that you have
this moment where Nick fury kind of pulls him aside and says,
you got his blessing, man, like you earned a kid, right?
If that's vitamin D real true, Spider-Man gives you his blessing,
then you're good. Right. Just go forward and do your superhero thing.
So it's really not anymore. Nick fury kind of questioning miles anymore,
kind of looking at him with a skewed eye or,
or really the only I can look at them at a look at them with, and just kinda,
you know, his, his one, his one good.
I kind of look at him with a skewed eye and then just kind of being like,
is he really going to be a good Spiderman at this point? You know,
he kind of goes forward with a whole new level of confidence that he didn't
really have before.
And that's kind of a cool thing because what you do is you switch over to Peter
Parker himself back home, right back in his own apartment. He's like miles,
Morales, miles Morales.
I wonder if we have a miles Morales in the main Marvel universe and then it ends
now of course we know as far as I'm aware, that's not true in, in Marvel comics.
Right. This story was told like eight years ago.
So we noticed not really true at the time this was written.
Everybody wanted to know if it was true or not. It was like the biggest,
biggest cliffhanger of like a decade. Right? Like I wonder if it's,
I wonder if they really do have a miles routes in the main Marvel universe and
it's like, I wonder what's going to happen with that. Right. It's kind of crazy,
but it is a cool story. Let me let you guys think down in the comment section.
Did you guys enjoy? Spider-Man the very first story,
the very first time where Peter Parker and miles Morehouse meet one another.
Let me know what you guys think. I'm kind of curious what your all stance is.
But with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments, explain,
make sure you guys get the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
Bruce.